-- SPECIAL ELECTION.
AND ANDERSON COOPER'S DOG ATE
HIS HOME WORK.
FIRST OPENING MONOLOGUE.
THE FALLOUT CONTINUES ON NEW
EXAMPLES OF POLITICAL BIAS CAN
FROM THE DEFENDANT
FROM THE DEFENDAN
FROM THE DEPANDAN
FROM THE DEPARTAN
FROM THE DEPARTME
FROM THE DEPARTMENT
FROM THE DEPARTMENT O
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF J
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF JUS
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTI
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
AND THE FBI.
FOX NEWS HAS SOME OF THE TEXT
MESSAGES BETWEEN PETER STRZOK
AND HIS FBI LAWYER GIRLFRIEND.
THEY ARE FULL OF TRUMP BASHING.
WE WILL SHOW YOU THE ACTUAL
MESSAGE IN A MINUTE.
THE MASSIVE CONFLICTS OF
INTEREST, THE POLITICAL
PREJUDICE BEING EXPOSED IN
AMERICA'S JUSTICE SYSTEM HAS
REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS DEMANDING
THEY QUESTIONED THE ROD
ROSENSTEIN ON CAPITOL HILL
INSIDER BIAS ON MR. MUELLER'S
TEAM.
FIRST WE HAVE FBI AGENT PETER
STRZOK AND FBI LAWYER LISA PAIGE
SHOWING EXTREME BIAS AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE SUPPOSED TO CURE THE
CONFLICT OF INTEREST HAVE EVEN
GREATER CONFLICTS OF INTEREST
A JURY KNOWING WHAT WE KNOW NOW.
WHY DIDN'T WE KNOW IT AHEAD OF
YOU SAY THAT THIS GROUP OF
DEMOCRAT PARTISANS ARE UNBIASSED
AND WILL GIVE PRESIDENT TRUMP A
FAIR SHAKE?
>> THIS IS UNBELIEVABLE!
I AM HEAR TO TELL YOU,
MR. ROSENSTEIN, THE PUBLIC TRUST
IN THIS WHOLE THING IS GONE.
YOU HAVE TWO THINGS CAN YOU DO.
YOU ARE THE GUY IN CHARGE.
YOU PICKED MUELLER.
YOU WROTE THE MEMO SAYING WHY
YOU NEEDED TO FIRE COMEY.
YOU ARE THE GUY IN CHARGE.
YOU CAN DISBAND THE MUELLER
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR AND APPOINT A
SECOND SPECIAL COUNCIL TO LOOK
FIRST.
-- MONTHS.
ROSENSTEIN REMAINED DEFIANT AND
DEFENDING MUELLER AND HIS TEAM
OF CLINTON LOVERS AND TRUMP
HATERS.
WATCH THIS.
>> IT'S IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT POLITICAL
AFFILIATION, THE ISSUE OF BIAS
IS SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
I DISCUSSED THIS WITH DIRECTOR
MUELLER.
WE HAVE A LOT OF EXPERIENCE
MANAGING EMPLOYEES WITH
POLITICAL OPINIONS.
IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE
I BELIEVE THAT DIRECT MUELLER
UNDERSTANDS THAT AND HE IS
RECOGNIZING THAT PEOPLE HAVE
POLITICAL VIEWS BUT ENSURING
THEY ARE NOT A FACTOR IN HOW
THEY CONDUCT HIMSELF.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE PRESIDENT
MEANT BY.
THAT THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
INVESTIGATION IS NOT A WITCH
HUNT.
>> Sean: THERE IS ONLY ONE
OPINION.
IT'S PRO-HILLARY AND ANTI-TRUMP.
A MOUNTAIN OF EVIDENCE SHOWING
THE BIAS AMONG MUELLER'S
INVESTIGATORS BUT ROSENSTEIN
PRETENDING LIKE HE DOESN'T SEE
IT.
WHAT IS HAPPENING?
THIS IS A DIRECT THREAT TO THE
RULE OF LAW IN THIS COUNTRY.
ROSENSTEIN IS AIDING AND
ABETTING THAT THREAT.
IF HE HAD ANY SORT OF MORAL
AS FOR MUELLER'S TEAM A QUICK
OVERVIEW.
THEY HAVE GIVEN PILES OF CASH,
OVER 50 GRAND IN TOTAL TO
DEMOCRATS INCLUDING BARACK OBAMA
AND HILLARY CLINTON.
ONLY ONE DONATEED TO A
REPUBLICAN.
NONE GAVE ANY MONEY TO DONALD
TRUMP.
ONE OF MUELLER'S TOP
THE CLINTON FOUNDATION DURING
THE 2015 RACKETEERING CASE.
THEN THERE IS MUELLER'S TOP
PROSECUTOR.
HE OVERSAW THAT CONTROVERSIAL
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE CASE.
REMEMBER ENRON?
IT DESTROYED THE COMPANY.
THEIR JOBS.
IN 2005 THE SUPREME COURT
INVESTIGATION, HE SENT 4 PEOPLE
TO JAIL AND THAT WAS ALL
OVERTURNED.
INTIMIDATING WITNESSES.
LAST WEEK WHY YOU  -- LAST WEEK
THEY RELEASED AN EMAIL.
YATES REFUSED TO ENFORCE THE
TRAVEL BAN.
WISEMAN ATTENDED HILLARY
CLINTON'S ELECTION NIGHT PARTY.
AND THEN THE TRUMP HATER PETER
STRZOK.
FOX NEWS HAS OBTAINED THE
MESSAGE BETWEEN STRZOK AND HIS
GIRLFRIENDS.
HERE'S THE BACK STORY.
THIS GUY STRZOK USED TO BE A TOP
COUNTER INTELLIGENT OFFICIAL
BEFORE BEING DEMOTED AND SIGNED
THE DOCUMENT THAT STARTED THE
ENTIRE RUSSIAN AND TRUMP
INVESTIGATION.
SECURITY ADVISOR MICHAEL FLYNN
AND PLAYED A MAJOR ROLE IN THE
CLINTON EMAIL INVESTIGATION.
INTERVIEWS OF CLINTON'S TOP
AIDES.
STRZOK IS THE GUY THAT CHANGED
THE EXONERATION BEFORE
INVESTIGATION JAMES COMEY.
HE CHANGED THE TERMINOLOGY FROM
HOOK.
STRZOK IS AT THE CENTER OF
EVERYTHING.
THAT'S WHY THESE TEXT MESSAGES
ARE SO DISTURBING.
LET'S LOOK AT THIS EXCHANGE.
PAIGE THE GIRLFRIEND WRITES
TRUMP IS A LOATHSOMEE HUMAN AND:
LATER STRZOK WROTE:
IN JUNE STRZOK WROTE:
WOW!
IN JULY, PAGE TEXTED:
?
AUGUST PAGE WROTE:
>> STRZOK EVEN BASHED TRUMP
SUPPORTERS.
WRITING:
>> Sean: IN OCTOBER STRZOK SENT
THIS MESSAGE:
MESSAGE PAY CLOSE ATTENTION TO.
IT'S RAISING IMPORTANT QUESTIONS
WE NEED ANSWERS TO.
IN AUGUST OF 2016, STRZOK
TEXTED:
>> Sean: FOX NEWS BELIEVES THAT
HIS WIFE TOOK DONATIONS FROM
DEMOCRACY.
THERE IS ALSO THIS TEXT
EXCHANGE.
WE EDITED OUT THE MIDDLE PART
THAT WAS A WEB LINK.
PAGE WRITES:
>> Sean: WHY IS THE INSURANCE
POLICY AND WHY IS ANDY THE
DEPUTY FBI DIRECTOR INVOLVED IN
REPORTED THAT THE MEETING WITH
MCCABE TOOK PLACE AS THE FBI
LAUNCHED A COUNTER-INTELLIGENCE
PROBE INTO POSSIBLE TRUMP AND
FBI ABOUT THE FAKE NEWS DOSSIER.
ANOTHER HUGE QUESTION:
HOW WERE THESE TEXT MESSAGES
DISCOVERED?
AFTER READING ALL OF THOSE.
HOW CAN ROD ROSENSTEIN GO BEFORE
CONGRESS TODAY AND CONCLUDE THAT
SPECIAL COUNSEL IS FAIR AND
UNBIASED?
AND FUSION GPS, THEY CONFIRMED
THAT NELLIE OHR THE WIFE OF THE
DOJ OFFICIAL BRUCE OHR WORKED
FOR FUSION GPS.
FUSION GPS ALSO CONFIRMED THAT
NELLIE OHR WORKED ON TRUMP
OPPOSITION RESEARCH.
WE FOUND OUT THAT BRUCE OHR MET
WITH THE FORMER BRITISH SPY THAT
PAID FOR THE RUSSIAN LIES TO
INFLUENCE THE ELECTION.
STEELE PUT TOGETHER THE FAKE
NEWS ANTI-TRUMP, RUSSIAN DOSSIER
WITH PHONEY INFORMATION.
BRUCE OHR MET WITH GLENN
SIMPSON.
THE CO-FOUNDER OF FUSION GPS.
GUESS WHAT?
OHR'S OFFICE WAS ONLY FOUR-DOORS
DOWN FROM ROSENSTEIN'S.
WOW.
EVERYTHING WE JUST EXPLAINED
SHOWS THAT THERE ARE INEXCUSABLE
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST.
THERE ARE CLEAR, ABUSIVE BIASES
AT THE DOJ AND THE FBI AND
ROBERT MUELLER'S TEAM.
TO BE CLEAR, THIS HAS NOTHING TO
DO WITH RANK-AND-FILE HARD
WORKING LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENTS.
THE LAW AND THINK THEY KNOW
BETTER THAN YOU.
WHAT IN GOD'S NAME IS ROBERT
WEB OF CORRUPTION.
IT'S ALL AIMED AT TAKING DOWN
THE ELECTED PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
WHAT HE IS DOING IS IMMORAL AND